you understand what's that when Katie
comes in exactly
there is no cohesion
so whatever you thought was about to
happen and by the way it's that way on
the show yeah contestant number one's
coming contestant number five is coming
no no no it's Luke is going to do
something crazy Katie's gonna do
something crazy and I'm sitting there
going guys Lionel you're the voice of
reason man I've been trying to be that
my whole life but
ABC has found a new Sandbox for me to
play it yeah with these two children
learning now called Luke and Katie I
know
have You Met My New Country Queen right
here this is two out of three oh my God
yeah the third is like the stressed he's
going over his line he's like will I do
it no we are going we are going to now
mess up Luke's entire performance
tonight because with us on the side of
the stage and in front of the stage
we're going but we don't have to do
anything but Justin support well but
this one is taking the stage with Thomas
Rhett tonight what is up your Denim and
rhinestone sleeve right there girlfriend
I'm just gonna be elevated and elegant
and maybe wear a cowgirl hat
it's so subtle let us be let us be
worried ladies and Gentlemen Just a
cowboy hat oh my God no I'm sorry y'all
have been around each other
I really actually might rush Luke and
Peyton tonight like she's not playing
she's so not playing just to be like I
am that girl you L.A you and Caroline
should okay I'm gonna get her on the
tequila train okay
we have to work tomorrow oh my God no no
but it's okay though one tequila
training
one Margarita two Margarita three
margarita
age get out of here y'all are being
called and I'm in trouble but I want to
talk to you mister I don't believe it
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah Mr Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame and ducky
I'm alive
I actually lived through it to actually
get can you believe that yes I can I am
so happy about this and by the way that
Hall of Fame thing was pretty much an
out-of-body experience because I you
know how you you can plan for just about
everything else but there are moments
that come along that you just if you get
it you get it you don't you don't when
they call my name I kept thinking what
just happened well I know come on well
you did you say hello yeah no I know but
remember that I grew up
in school yeah with the stones and come
on you know so when you all of a sudden
you start thinking about
that's that's that's judah's priest
coming in on my class I'm not surprised
though when I sat down with you last
year at the induction ceremony we were
chatting about Alex Avon and I'm
thinking this man sitting beside of me
needs to be getting his flowers you know
what it is this it's one of those
wonderful moments I got to tell you I
think more importantly having my kids in
the audience and saying oh my god dad
what is this all about because they
missed the whole story you know what I'm
saying and so from The Commodores all
the way through to that moment
you know I mean it's just a big Flash in
in life and so I'm just enjoying the
ride here well you ready because you got
more
of everybody you know what an AMA is
basically my family because when I when
I say that sincerely Dick Clark called
me on the phone and said you're hosting
the show and I said but I don't know how
to host the show he said you will after
you finish and that was my answer and by
the way we did what three shows in a row
yeah two shows but it was live three
hours of hang on to your seat here comes
Prince Here Comes Springsteen I mean it
was
are crazy
[Music]